nous commençons cette nouvelle année sur
la route du sud est ce qui attire en
premier notre attention c'est ce petit
marché d'où de coco qui ne désemplit pas
au lendemain du réveillon de la saint
sylvestre l'eau de ce fruit est très
prisé elle a des vertus drainantes
énergisantes mais aussi digestives
un bon moyen de se remettre en forme
naturellement
fait du bien je n'ai pas bougé pas
consommer irait donc mais ça fait du
bien mais c'est aussi bien pour d'autres
personnes que je vois là je pense qu'ils
qui sont en train de faire des cendres
et de la lave et l'alcool quelques
kilomètres plus loin sur la plage de
fond banane à sainte luce c'est le
moment du premier bain de l'année
l'eau de mer a aussi ses bienfaits
revigorante apaisante rafraîchissante
un bon moyen de démarrer 2020
chevènement pieds dans le sable et
soleil à profusion moi je suis en
vacances et je me suis dit avant de
repartir benjamines à prendre un petit
bain
surtout on n'a pas ça souvent le soleil
puis pour bien commencer l'année courir
tue encore dû faire un peu de sport sur
la plage ça me change bien le programme
d'un bon début d'année pour certains
c'est être bien dans sa peau et dans sa
tête un peu de nage un peu de marche un
peu de méditation une bonne demi-heure
de dommages
essaoui gel cellules et ça fait du bien
je veux être en forme pour affronter les
différentes difficultés nager c'était
qu'on dirait faire ce qu'il faut pour
démarrer la nouvelle année en bonne
santé surtout la plage comme l'un des
meilleurs lieux de ce premier jour de
l'année il y en a pour tous les goûts
pour tous les styles y compris pour ceux
qui veulent être zen et détendu le 1er
janvier
c'est sûr qu'un bon massage au bruit des
vagues fait toujours du bien